Some people invest in real estate
because they don't want to invest in
banks. But they claim that the zakat on
such wealth has to be paid only on its
rent and not on its original value. What
is your observation on this issue?
As far as the view of the majority of
the scholars is concerned, what they say
that if the land has been purchased for
selling so that you make a profit, then
all the scholars unanimously agree that
zakat should be paid on it. As we
discussed in the last answer that the
moment one year is completed, the land
that you purchase, zakat has to bear on
it. But if you have land and if you give
it on rent mean if you buy a house and
give it on rent. Majority of the
scholars say that zakat is not
applicable on the value of the house.
Zakat is only applicable on the rent you
receive. The moment you receive the rent
and if it stays with you for a period of
one year and if it's above the nisab
level then you have to pay zakat on the
rent not on the value of the house the
flat or the land. But nowadays most of
the people that purchase land for
investment they give it on rent. So here
we are in a dilemma that people who
purchase land mainly the purpose of
investment but if they think that
they'll buy the land they sell after
four five years when the price rises. So
but natural they don't want to keep it
vacant. So they give it on rent to a
person who requires to stay in that
flat. Now what will happen? Should we
pay zakat or not? So here there's a
difference
opinion. Here scholars differ. Some
scholars say that fine pay only zakat on
the rent if you possess it for more than
one year if it's above nab level and
when you sell it on that year only you
pay the 2 and a half% of the total value
of the land. But there are some
scholars who are very strict and who
disagree with this view and they say
that if you buy a land even if you give
it on
rent the cost of the land the market
value of that land or of that flat
should be paid every hij year. Scholars
like Akil they say
this
Arabi Akil who's a
humbly Arabi who is a Maliki Shik Abu
Zora who's a Hanafi Abdul Raman
Al-Hassan
Shik Abdulaf
Khalaf who is presently a very great
scholar Shik Kardavi
And scholars of the same group they say
that if a
person buys and has many flats on
rent then he should even pay zakat on
the cost of that flat of that land. But
for example if a person is a poor person
and doesn't have any income doesn't have
any business and he has only one house
which he's living and a second house
which he gives on rent. So unanimously
people agree that the rent he acquires
if it saving is more than sub level. But
there are many rich people who are
landlords and who possesses many houses
many flats which they give on rent. They
own large properties and if we agree
with the view of the majority of the
scholars that zakat should be only paid
on the rent. Suppose a person has 100
flats costing hundreds of thousands of
dollars and the rent that he
gets he utilizes what is required for
his personal expenses and before one
year is over after he gets the rent he
buys another few flats.
So and if he doesn't have any gold
jewelry that means he will not pay zakat
at all after the 100 flats become 110
120 140 maybe he is one of the richest
man in the city of Bombay or any city he
may own half the property of the city
half the land in the city so if you
agree that zakal should not be paid he
may be a
multi-billionaire may own half the city
may own three-/4th of the city he takes
rent when he gets the
before it becomes one year, he utilizes
what he wants. Then he buys new land and
if zakat is not there on land which is
given on rent, he will keep on getting
richer and richer and richer without
paying a single dollar as zakat. So
therefore I agree more with the minority
group of scholars like Arabi Akil Shikh
Abu Zora Shik Karavi and the likes of
these scholars who say that if a person
possesses a large amount of land and
many houses giving on rent then zakat
should be even paid on the cost price of
the land of the flat. Whatever is the
present value of that land or of that
house he has to pay 2.5% zakat every hij
year I agree more with these type of
scholars and anyway even if it's not
required a person pays extra question
you surely you will get sab for that
even if you give a satka you'll get sab
so I always agree when in doubt leave it
out and go on the side which will give
more sab because minimum is 2 and person
zakat. If you pay more, Allah will yet
be